sur fond de paso-doble et pallois hier
que voici la toute nouvelle collection
100 et hop une collection très spéciale
puisqu'elle s'apprête exclusivement au
personnel hôtelier
fini le traditionnel qui uniforme noir
et blanc objectif des créateurs
conquérir le marché espagnol ici 92
l'année des jeux olympiques de barcelone
que l'espagne peut donner un nouvel look
descente tourisme d'améliorer son
service et alors où j'avais trouvé des
qu'effectivement en espagne y manquait
ses côtes espagnoles mais moderne
alors je me suis unis avec la créatrice
laura la rue
pour faire ce que on a vu tout je
voudrais que ce soit plus gai on la sent
bien qu'il est dans ces élus là aussi je
suis un peu et que les femmes soient
avec des jupes et les hommes ça rigole
donc j'ai mélangé l'afrique et l'espagne
ce coup là et le gers est un peu le cas
stressé pendant tout le professionnel
heures villiers prototype la mélodie
drones et laura va ci lui ont choisi une
petite entreprise de castres la vive à
theix spécialisée dans la fabrication de
vêtements professionnels pour les
secteurs hospitalier industriels ou
commerciaux
cette unité de production emploie
aujourd'hui une dizaine de personnes un
effectif qui devrait d'ailleurs doublé
dans les prochains mois car les
créateurs envisagent déjà d'exporter
leurs collections tout un clan qui
s'était produit en gaz comme très mal
europe parce que des fois on est vissé
dans les marchés européens mais
effectivement par exemple les 17 avril
on s'en va avec la collection au mexique
où on a proposé aux chaînes mexicaines
une collection nouvelle avec les côtés
barcelone 92 après les robes à volants
il faut s'attendre une entrée
fracassante
mutzig 1 dans la prochaine collection
avantage incontestable me direz vous
pour le service hôtelier
il peut à la fois ses billets comme quoi
des deux plateaux à jouer du politique